Call them what you will, be it myths, urban
legends, ghost tales or just fool yarns; the
fact is we’ve all heard at least one.
Traditionally, stories like that were just
shared around a campfire, but nowadays they
have ended up spreading far and wide across
internet message boards and creepy threads.
Everything ranging from unsolved missing persons
cases actually being the
result of alien abductions,
to haunted videos carrying an unforgiving
curse or some missing, unaired episode of
popular tv shows that had somehow been unearthed
by an online sleuth.
We’re always quick to share these ideas,
these stories, but deep down a part of us
knows that there’s no truth to them.
Urban myths are speculation that someone has
turned into a tale of terror, for nothing
more than to give some quick scares to whoever
they tell it to.
But then that person passes that tale on to
someone else, and suddenly the story had become
a widespread legend with no discernible point
of origin.
Sure, they might still be fictional, but through
sharing these stories, we as humans bring
them to life.
Not literally, of course,
that would be outlandish.
After all, when was the last time you heard
of a fictional story becoming reality…?
Growing up with exposure and unfiltered access
to the internet in the late 2000s, Paul Jacobs
and his friends had been fascinated with – and
admittedly, pretty terrified by – the notorious
legend of the Slender Man.
It began as whisperings in an online forum,
a story that was intentionally designed to
be a modern day urban myth.
And just like so many others before it, the
myth spread.
What had started as a forum post became unnerving
photoshopped images of a tall, faceless figure
in a suit lurking in the woods, next an indie
video game, and even a real world tragedy.
Given how young he was at the time – still
being in high school – Paul and a few others
had bought into the Slender Man myth wholesale.
He believed it to be real, this towering,
expressionless boogeyman.The more he learned
about this malevolent creature, every story,
blog post or creepy YouTube video made about
Slender Man, only added more and more to his
legend, and kept young Paul awake at night,
afraid that every noise outside his bedroom
window was the faceless horror.
Of course, if you take away that belief, the
possibility an urban legend might be true,
then it simply loses its power.
It’s that potential, that maybe, toeing
the line between fantasy and reality, that
can allow these stories to go on and incite
fear forever.
But that wasn’t the case for the Slender
Man story, and the craze for it quickly died
down after it was debunked numerous times
over, casting it permanently back into the
realm of fiction.
But the profound effect the legend had on
Paul at a young age ended up informing his
future.
As he grew older, his past fear of certain
stories became a keen interest in how these
tales could influence people.
Could any story have that same impact, or
only those that walked the line between being
fictional and maybe being true?
Did these urban legends become more real to
people because of their subject matter, or
did human beings give them that power to transcend
the constraints of fiction just by believing
in them?
As Paul got older, he began to study the truth
behind certain urban legends, attempting to
trace them back to their origins.
Some were often inspired by real events, but
with specific details that had gradually been
altered from the original story the more and
more people passed it around.
Ghost stories seemed to be the most changeable,
but with some roots in the real world.
A person might have died a hundred years ago,
and the story of them haunting their old home
or final resting place would start to circulate.
Then, shortly after, another similar story
might emerge, and the two would overlap.
Whoever was telling each story might have
added or omitted certain details, or combined
elements of more than one tale, until what
was left being passed around was neither the
first story nor the second, but a hybrid of
different versions from different storytellers.
There was one legend that Paul felt drawn
to more than others, and it was a rather obscure
one to say the least.
During his self-conducted research into stories
of this nature, he learned about a tale that
told of an ancient sect called the Daevites.
According to legends – some that dated so
far back they preceded almost all recorded
history – these Daevites were a callous
and cruel civilization.
They had emerged from a book, so the story
went, and sought only to wage war on other
cultures and enslave their enemies.
But Paul also uncovered one detail of the
story that intrigued him more than any other.
It referred to something known as the ‘Eternal
Text’, and was regarded as some kind of
deity or figure of worship by the Daevites.
The legends stated that this Text had helped
create the book that they had emerged from.
Of course, this all sounded like highly fictitious
nonsense to Paul Jacobs.
He knew that things of such nature didn’t
exist in the real world, they were only part
of stories.
But he had noticed that this particular story
seemed to have passed its way through the
ages.
Searching further, Paul had uncovered the
works of an obscure author from the United
States, who had only a few works that were
known about during the 1940s and 50s.
Even then, most of his stories weren’t widely
published, only a few shorter pieces making
it into a magazine that had long since stopped
being printed.
This writer had died in 1957, having never
seen his career in fiction come to much fruition.
But, despite his short-lived career and being
considered a somewhat sub-par author at the
time, the writer’s work had garnered its
own little cult following online, mostly comprised
of amateur authors.
It was through them that Paul managed to obtain
some scanned copies of the anonymous writer’s
stories, particularly some that he felt bore
a striking similarity to the Daevite legends
of the Eternal Text.
One story in particular – written in a style
lifted directly from H.P.
Lovecraft – was based on a supposed encounter
the writer claimed to have had with something
that closely resembled the Eternal Text.
Paul also studied the writer’s own personal
journals that he had managed to recover scans
of.
The entries from it seemed to imply that the
author came across what he called the ‘Written
God’ and that this compelled him to write
a fictional version of those events.
It was only after writing
about this new encounter,
that what he had depicted in his story seemed
to come true, exactly as he’d written them.
This led to a recursive process of the writer
creating these encounters, only for them to
occur, thus causing him to write about it
and then make it happen.
The entire prospect not only confused and
bewildered Paul, but intrigued him further
as well.
Although he had no way of confirming what
this writer had claimed was true, Paul believed
that on a smaller scale, the author had achieved
the same effect that occurs during the passing
down of urban legends.
But the difference here was, that it had all
been done through himself, via a singular
person telling variations on the same story,
allowing it to continue
and perpetuate recursively.
Of course, Paul didn’t actually believe
in this ‘Written God’ or ‘Eternal Text’,
those were all just part of the fiction.
But he wanted to experiment further, and see
if he could achieve the same
process for himself.Taking
an empty notebook, Paul started to write the
first things that came to mind, basing a short
story off of the anonymous’ authors own
tale.
He intentionally changed a few key details,
noting down things that weren’t in the original.
“The Written God appeared behind me,”
he wrote, adding on a whim the line: “It
had no face.”
The whole intention of Paul’s experiment
was to pass his new version of the story on
to someone else, and then try to get them
to write it from memory.
He wanted to observe if their mind would change
certain details subconsciously, or if they
would misremember elements when they retold
their new version.
If enough people could spread the story around,
each time altering or adding new parts to
it, what effect could it have?
As he finished his rewritten version of the
author’s tale, attaching it to an email
to send to one of his fellow writers, Paul
was blissfully unaware of just what he’d
done.
A heavy knocking rang out, somebody’s fist
pounding at the front door loud enough to
wake him.
Bleary-eyed, Paul checked the alarm clock
next to his bed; it was the middle of the
night.
Stumbling out of bed, he staggered his way
towards the repetitive noise, unsure who…
or what would be calling this late.
Paul froze for a second, casting his mind
back to the story he had written earlier.
Surely not, it couldn’t be, right?
It was just a story after all.
But the author, he had described how the things
he’d written had come true.
There it was, that possibility, that maybe…
what if it was behind the door right now?
Suddenly, something much heavier than a hand
bashed against the wooden surface of the front
door, causing it to fly open, the catch of
the lock being ripped out of the wall by the
force of the impact.
A group of black-clad figures rushed in, one
of them tackling Paul to the ground before
he could even process what was happening.
The weight of another person pinned him down
and kept him from moving despite his attempts
at struggling free.
Then, the feeling of something sharp poked
at the exposed skin of Paul’s neck, a needle
filled with… he wasn’t sure, all he really
knew right now was how dizzy he was.
Unable to stop himself from slipping away,
the sedative quickly put Paul back to sleep,
as the agents filed into his home.
The floor he woke up on was freezing cold.
Blinking his heavy eyelids until they opened
again, Paul did his best to stand.
His head was still spinning, making it hard
to keep his feet still, and to make matters
worse, the room around him was hardly lit.
Only a few low fluorescents dimly illuminated
the tiny space.
“Mr. Jacobs,” a voice boomed over a crackly
intercom, the pitch lowered to distort it
further, “We need you to answer a few questions
for us.”
“What?”
Paul responded in confusion.
“Where did you first learn about SCP-582?”
the voice questioned, barely giving Paul a
moment to think.
“About what?
What’s an SCP?” he asked back.
“You wrote a story earlier today, correct?”
boomed the unseen speaker.
Meekly, Paul nodded his head.
“We monitor online activity for any mentions
of SCP-582, or anything using any of its known
aliases.”
“You mean that Written God, Eternal Text
thing?”
Paul replied, catching on to what the voice
had been referring to.
“I read about it in some stories by this
old author, he died ages ago, most of his
work is pretty niche, it’s actually hard
to track down-”
“Enough,” the voice interjected bluntly.
“When did you specify SCP-582 would manifest?”
‘
“Manifest?” he raised an eyebrow, confused
again.
“It was just a story, that’s what I was
doing, I was examining stories and how they
change when they get passed on.”
“Mr. Jacobs.”
It sounded as though the voice had shifted,
still distorted but now calmer, more collected;
somebody else was speaking.
“It’s important you answer our questions,
your life could very well be in danger.
Now, do you remember when you wrote that SCP-582
– when it – was going to appear?”
“What do you mean ‘in danger’?”
Paul retorted in a panic.
“Who the heck even are you people?”
“Calm down, Mr. Jacobs.”
He looked down to see his hands were trembling,
suddenly aware of the sweat coating his forehead.
Paul took a series of deep breaths, trying
to collect himself.
“I…
I don’t remember,” he sighed, his voice
now shaking as much as the rest of him was.
“What about a location?”
the voice pressed him.
“Can you tell us where it’s going to appear?”
“I didn’t write a location either,”
Paul answered, “I just said it appeared…”
The words he had written earlier quickly came
crashing back into his head, almost like an
urgent warning.
“Behind me…”
As he spoke, Paul could sense someone standing
near him, that same sensation you get when
you know another person is in the room, even
when you haven’t looked directly at them
yet.
Paul tried to keep his head forward, only
tilting it slightly to the side, seeing something
dark looming just behind his shoulder.
He couldn’t rationalize any of what was
happening, too scared to turn all the way
around.
Doing that would mean admitting all of this
was real, and not just some horrific nightmare…
not just a story.
“We, uh,” for the first time, the voice
over the intercom sounded uneasy.
“We think you need to turn around, Mr. Jacobs.”
Telling himself he’d wake up any second,
Paul rotated with his eyes screwed shut, snapping
them open once he was facing…
nothing.
A blank space, lacking any expression and
all of the normal features was looming over
him with an empty, eyeless stare.
It had no face, just like in Paul’s story.
He opened his mouth to let out a scream, only
for it to be interrupted by the crunching
sounds of neck bones twisting the wrong way.
As Paul’s lifeless body dropped back down
to the cold floor, SCP-582 vanished just as
quickly as it had arrived.
***
The thing about some anomalies is, you have
to be very careful about how you talk about
them.
Not just because they could be listening in
and might hear you, but because what you say
about them might just have a nasty habit of
coming true.
That’s the case with SCP-582, otherwise
known as its rather apt nickname ‘A Bundle
of Stories’.
What’s so fitting about that title is its
accuracy, that’s all SCP-582 really is:
stories.
But therein lies its true power.
This entity has a way of
propagating and perpetuating
itself, continuously adapting and spreading
like a mutating virus.
Except it doesn’t pass from person to person
as an illness, there are no symptoms.
It transmits via stories.
SCP-582 is subject to a process of passive
reality manipulation; it doesn’t necessarily
directly change the world around it, but can
itself be changed by certain factors.
What this means is, anything said or written
about this entity, even if pulled out of thin
air, a fictional account of its deeds…
all becomes real.
Let’s say, for example, you told a story
about SCP-582 sneaking up behind a Foundation
researcher when his back was turned.
Telling that story would cause those exact
events would be carried out in the real world.
When SCP-582 manifests, it
will do so in accordance
with any details given in a fictional account
about it; the same time, the same place on
Earth, it would appear in the exact form that
the tale specified.
If any of those details were omitted, or purposely
left vague, then the entity would still be
able to manifest, and would do so in a way
that fits the rest of the narrative, appearing
wherever and whenever it has an opportunity
to.
As far as the researchers at the SCP Foundation
can tell, the actual abilities of SCP-582
are usually left vague when people write about
it.
One of the few consistencies is that the entity
can disappear and reappear at will, to any
place or time.
Another is that no method of harming or even
killing SCP-582 has ever worked, even if written
down as fiction in order to be made fact.
Any other details or abilities that someone
assigns to the creature will, however, become
a permanent addition to its growing myth,
meaning it is able to perpetually increase
its power the more people write about it.
On the rare occasion multiple different writers’
accounts of SCP-582 contradict each other,
or don’t fit into the entity’s own ‘canon’,
it can easily adapt to these contradictions.
This usually results in conflicting information
having no effect on the Bundle of Stories,
or having so little impact that it is almost
like they didn’t happen at all.
In short, if one author’s story doesn’t
quite match up with another’s, then the
effect these additions have to SCP-582 and
its ongoing story are lessened so that they
can all either logically occur, or be negated
completely.
It is because of this adaptability, and that
it has been described by multiple sources,
that portrayals of SCP-582 tend to be generalized.
This even extends down to its appearance;
it’s currently unknown what the entity’s
true form is, or if it even has one.
However, the fact that it is usually depicted
as a deity or god, means that this Bundle
of Stories has been known to manifest as one
of several avatars.
The most common of these appearances is that
of a humanoid being, standing well over six
feet tall.
When manifesting as this particular form,
SCP-582 is dressed in thickly layered robes,
made from burlap – or hessian – complete
with a hood.
However, no face is visible underneath the
creature’s hood, and when presenting as
this avatar, it is often described as carrying
sacks of unknown contents, sometimes even
appearing to bleed heavily.
There have been a number of other incarnations
of SCP-582 including a six-legged form that
is made out of pure molten tar and will attack
any nearby human beings on sight.
This avatar would normally appear as being
fused with the first.
In other instances, it has appeared as a plant
capable of producing both light and enough
radiation to kill anyone in its radius within
a few hours of exposure.
Other times, it has been a vaguely human shaped
shadow, and even has one form that exists
within more than three dimensions.
Due to this form existing on higher dimensions,
this made it impossible to properly perceive
with the naked eye, and resulted in the deaths
of anyone who looked even partially at it.
Who knows, maybe at some point it has even
been described as a tall, slender figure in
a dark suit, with pale skin and a face with
its eyes, ears, nose, and mouth all missing?
Actually, it’s probably best that nobody
writes it down, we don’t want it becoming
real now, do we?
The question is, how can you hope to contain
or even fight something that can be anything,
anywhere, and have any strength that someone
claims it has?
Well, just to be on the safe side, the Foundation
uses its own fictional narrative to keep the
entity contained.
It is their hope that, by describing it as
powerless, it will turn the creature’s own
reality-altering properties against it, and
actually cause SCP-582 to lose its abilities.
“What thoughts, if any, that flow through
that alien mind are not mine to know: It remains
silent and still within its chamber, entrenched
in the persistence of its own memory.
It remains, but only as a shade of what it
was, its power spent, or at least come to
rest.”
So, remember, SCP-582 possesses no actual
consciousness or free will.
Anything it has ever said or done is because
someone wrote that it would.
And yes, we’re only saying that because
we don’t want to write that it’s broken
free from containment and is currently standing
behind you… if we did that, it might just
come true.
Now go and check out “SCP-023 THE BLACK
SHUCK” for another anomalous entity that
has slipped its way into the zeitgeist of
mythology and legend.
Or if you’re looking for more monsters of
memetic madness, then why not get yourself
acquainted with “SCP-2440 THE SEALED KING”!